[Applause]
oh brave as a button you sicko
he's in the makings to be an absolute
beast what a goalie i love that
very good if that's a standard to start
with then we're going to surely see some
absolute worldly saves today
he's put it top binzel absolute top
schnitzel
goalie top hand save gary neville would
have been fuming because he saved it
with his top hand
for me that's a welding all right we've
got some
shaky camera work goalies up though it's
got to be last minute of the game last
kick of the game
oh my god he's got it as well oh golly
you absolute legend
phenomenal that's my that's my life
dream in one clip there
the amount of corners i've come up for
in the 94th minute
dreaming of getting on the end of
something and putting it in the back of
the net
that's my dream right there i've had it
happen against me paul robertson scored
from about 500 yards away
it was horrible it is what it is though
one day
one day i think i might retire after it
as well if i do it
oh come on then little man love this
oh brave as a button you sicko
no joe when i was eight or nine years
old there was no way i was running out
and jumping
like that at attacker's feet that is
unbelievable he's got
he's in the makings to be an absolute
beast what a goalie i love that
okay free kick in their own half good
ball over the top
keepers out oh no lad what are you doing
[Applause]
this is world class he's out the picture
you can't see him all the lad's got to
do is put it in the back of the net
goalie comes out saves the day as per
usual
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god what a save that's a pro save
that's like
something you'd see a professional make
even the attack is standing on the goal
line still
in absolute disbelief even he can't
believe it
the the best save i've ever seen on
telly is david seaman save
against sheffield united in the fa cup
it's literally you're talking fingertips
it's phenomenal
oh paula this right in his ghoulies as
well i can feel the pain
we were training i think it was last
week i think it was actually tom
cleverley he's come through one-on-one
i've just had to sort of
spread myself hope for the best that it
hits me
and yeah it hit me there straight in the
crown jewels
the worst part about it was though that
the ball kind of just popped out and he
just
the football just popped out and he just
put it in the back of the net
right deep free kick 40 yards out
goalie is absolutely on his line there's
no way he's coming out for the cross
oh lad oh lad lad lad
it's a shame a lot i can't help you mate
we
i need to get you down we'll do a little
training session or something for them
that's a simple catch
oh he's throw go on spread yeah save
oh foot save love it triple save
quadruple save
off the line
the post oh oh my god
oh my days i'm on the edge of my seat
oh that's incredible goalie that's
the finest save montage i think he's
made six or seven saves there
world class very very good okay in third
place
we have got this absolute
tragedy to triumph or look at this now
he's nowhere to be seen
out of the picture impossible save
world-class
striker thinks he's putting in the back
of the net the goal he comes from
absolutely nowhere
superman head first brave as a button
saves the day
okay second place is this little legend
ball comes through
look how brave he is here watch this
watch us are you sicko mate
is he it's even hit his hand behind him
as well it's a goal brave as you like
down at feet taking players all over the
shop
little legend and in first place is this
absolute sicko of six or seven saves
that's three
that's four off the line oh my days this
is what dreams are made of
off the post goalie says off the line oh
wow
mate that's the best montage
of consecutive saves i've ever seen in
my life
take a bow you are the winner incredible
stuff
[Music]
that's incredible all right saggy stop